la loi veil a aujourd'hui 25 ans cela
fait un quart de siècle que madame veil
avait défendu devant l'assemblée
nationale la légalisation de
l'avortement
la lutte des femmes françaises su après
un combat souvent provocateurs comme
nous le rappelle agnès molinier la
guillotine pour les avorteuse les
assises pour leur cliente de simone de
beauvoir à catherine deneuve
ces scories risques et ces femmes jusqu
aux années 40 en france car elles ont
toutes reconnu publiquement avoir eu
recours à une interruption de grossesse
alors que c'était illégal 343 nom paraît
171 dans le nouvel observateur
on les appelle les [ __ ] les gens
riches pouvaient apporter en suisse les
pauvres c'était encore parce que les
aiguilles à tricoter ou les sondés tout
ça et des gens les femmes on mourrait ou
était très malade devenait après ce
terrible où on enlever les ovaires
parce qu'ils avaient des infections qui
se passait donc tout ça si vous voulez a
fait que je veux pas signer par
provocation les six n'est pas sain pas
évident ces femmes célèbres ne font que
relayer la voix de la rue le combat
féministe est à son comble après la
contraception autorisé en 69
la légalisation de l'avortement devient
le nouvel enjeu en soi 112
l'acquittement d'une jeune fille ayant
interrompu sa grossesse et pour les
militantes une première victoire
74 les politiques essentiellement des
hommes prennent enfin la mesure de
l'urgence 300 femmes meurent chaque
année d'avortements clandestins contre
certains ténors de son camp simone veil
se bat et elle gagne avec plus de
difficulté que si elle avait été un
homme
je crois que jeune femme avait
plus de facilités pour faire comprendre
la détresse des femmes pour faire
comprendre le problème mais
mais qui n'y aurait pas eu ces attaques
personnelles ce qui se voulait vraiment
humiliante personnellement enfin
s'attaquant à votre personne aujourd'hui
des femmes sont à nouveau dans la rue
elles défendent un meilleur accès à liv
et j'ai un quart de siècle après le
combat de leur mère